i'm good to go
good morning welcome to this joint
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
i'm councillor keith welland and i'm
chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you may maintain
social distance
from all other persons in the chamber
and in the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking
or if you are unable to do so
and that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting
and during any breaks please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave please ensure
your mobile phones are on silent or
switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting
on the modern.gov app
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are
or exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
so can i move to the agenda please
what's the logic of wearing a mask when
you're not speaking
but when you're speaking you can take
your mask off
um surely particle
go when you're speaking not when you're
not speaking i just
wonder what the logic of this
arrangement is
well we have advice we've had advice
somebody on
on the procedure do you want to answer
that
please chair i'm happy to
try and assist with the question our
current risk assessment for use of this
room as
a meeting space requires that
we wear face coverings if you're not
covered by one of the reasons that
excludes you from wearing face covering
however we do keep that under continual
review with government guidance
and i do know that the health and safety
officer was here on friday having a look
at the room again so
that advice may change in terms of
speaking you've got your face uncovered
when you're not speaking you cover
um please could you tell me where the
risk is
um if you're not
speaking doesn't seem to make any sense
so the the reason for removing masks
when you're speaking is because
obviously it's quite muffled
in the microphones and particularly for
members of public who may be watching on
the live stream
and hopefully most people will be
talking for a very short amount of time
and therefore the risk is reduced by
just removing it for a short amount of
time
thank you chair
once that we've been given well it's
it's it's what the risk assessment has
stated so that is
that is the procedure for the meeting
thank you
so moving to the agenda apologies for
absence and substitutions
do we have any please good morning chair
uh we have received um apologies from
council grandin
and council fleming the cabinet member
for environment has kindly forwarded her
apology as well thank you
um declarations of interest are there
any declarations of interest
please
[Music]
sure um i'd like to declare your
interest as a member of mit suffer
software holdings limited thank you very
much
can we now turn to the minutes of the
meeting held on 24th of may 2021 there
any points regarding the accuracy of the
minutes please
cancel rapping now thank you chair um i
think with regard to
[Music]
item six zero point one one um
in the last uh though sorry the
penultimate sentence
uh it ought to be however she thought
so this was sixty point
eight was it it's on page nine chairs
sixty
point one one point eleven oh sorry uh
i haven't got page numbers on my sorry
so it's
it's a paragraph that begins the
monitoring officer had experienced
exactly
however she thought yes on the fifth
line
it's just to add a t to the indeed to
the word
thank you very much
having made that amendment
are you happy for me to sign the minutes
if so can i have a proposal please
counselor under second to please
councillor carter thank you very much
so a governance officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
yes members if you go to the plus sign
at the top of your agenda
and go under attendance and voting you
will scroll down and you will see
there's a blue line
can you please click on that and that's
where you have to vote thank you
so chair that is uh nine votes four
and uh one abstention
is correct counselor mabry
you were not at the meeting uh at the
end of the meeting
so i will abstain
so there is nine votes for and two
abstentions thank you very much the
minutes of the meeting
are confirmed
to receive a notification of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme are there any please
and receive chair thank you very much
questions by the public
thank you chair we have received two
questions from
uh one from mr roger young and one for
mr thomas morelli
and which the chair will now read to the
committee
i'm just checking for the council young
question
the question from mr roger young is why
was it necessary for cifco capital
limited to allocate
983 269 new shares on the 20th
of the first 2021 to each shareholder
bce and msdc and when
and where were the bdc councillors
informed and subsequently
agreed to such action there is a
supplementary question
but i feel it's better to take these
questions
when we come to the the item
eight as they refer directly to item
eight
so we will leave those
those questions until then
and i have i have here the
the question from mr thomas morelli
the joint overview and scrutiny
committee last scrutinized the shared
legal service in july 2018.
since that time there have been a number
of occasions
relating to successful or conceded legal
challenges against
baba and or mid-suffolk district council
most recently the claim for judicial
review
brought by boxwood parish council which
was part conceded by baber
this raises the potential issue of the
quality of advice being provided by the
shared legal service
in addition given the time that has
elapsed since the committee's last
review of the shared legal service it
would seem prudent
for updated scrutiny of the of the by
the committee
to be conducted given all this will the
overview and scrutiny committee
commit to carrying out a full review of
the work undertaken by
the shared legal service to ensure that
it is still performing in line with
expectations
and is providing good value for council
taxpayers
and my response is this members of this
committee will be reviewing their
forward work plans are items
13 and 14 of today's agenda and will
consider
as part of these items the request
for a full review of the shared legal
service
thank you
[Applause]
item six item six is questions by
councillors
do we have any do we have any questions
by councillors
chair we have received um a couple of
questions for council grandin who is
member of the committee who is absent
today
um i i'm not sure would you prefer to
read them now or would you prefer to
read them under the items for where they
are directed at yes thank you they they
are
questions which directly relate to item
eight
and i would prefer to read them at item
eight um
at the same well not at the same time as
the previous questions that we've
referred to but following those
questions so if
if you're all content we will leave
those questions as they rely
relate to the civical item we will leave
them
until then thank you
so we no more questions jim
thank you very much
so we move on to item 7 which is an
executive summary
of the sifko capital limited business
trading and performance report
for 2020 and 2021
and i invite emily a tac to present
this executive summary
good morning uh all the executive
summary
is just of a business plan
report and um document that has been
provided
um at the request of the chairs to help
aid this meeting so i hope it has been
beneficial and we have um
a presentation to deliver and i know
that councillor gold has a brief uh
introduction uh into the main um report
and um a business plan that's being
presented
so i don't think the executive summary
necessarily needs to be discussed in in
isolation but
happy too if that would be helpful
yes thank you very much so we will move
on to
item eight so
please note that the report included in
the agenda pack is the draft report
to full council and that the
recommendations
in the report are for council this
committee has to make
our own recommendations to council
the joint overview and scrutiny
committee will be examining the
robustness of the business plan and not
the governance structures of cifco or
the basis under which it was set up
or any decisions relating to that or its
terms of reference
i'm unlikely to allow questions in those
areas as they fall outside the area
of responsibility of this committee
and would be a matter for each full
council
please note that any questions by
non-committee members should be for
point of clarity
and for i and for the item discussed as
the debate itself will be for the
committee
and for the committee members only
if we have got any non-committee members
they will wait with their questions for
clarity until all committee members have
completed their questions
i will move to item 15 the resolution to
exclude
the public up to the up to the agenda
uh to the end of the open session for
item item 8 if the committee decides
it needs to go into closed session to
consider the confidential part
of the agenda so i'd now like to
invite visit councillor gould who is
going to give the introduction present
the report and then following that is it
for the assistant director to give her
presentation
after that presentation we will then
take
questions from members questions for
clarity
from members of this committee
thank you chair i'm grateful uh for the
opportunity
to uh to present uh the the reports
um i'm pleased to introduce a report
detailing
cifco's capital performance over the
last 12 months
and the proposed business plan for the
next 12 months
the business plan is a fundamental part
of
sifko's governance and ensures
accountability to its shareholders
and i value this input from the overview
and scrutiny
committee in this regard and as the
chair
i think has helped me set the questions
for the committee to address
are those proposed by him and set out
in paragraph 1.2 of the executive
summary
report transparency is important to us
as a public body
though clearly the council's commercial
interests
require some confidentiality
i will take a moment to mention the
sifko website
which itself helps to promote
understanding
and accountability accountability
cifco has provided the councils with
close to
5.5 million pounds uh
net of net income since its inception in
2017.
delivering approximately 2.2 million to
the councils during the last financial
year
was facing unprecedented challenges
as a consequence of the pandemic and
certainly providing the councils with
much
needed income at this time
i think even the most enthusiastic
designer
of business stress tests would not have
thought of anything
as severe as the pandemic yet cifco has
been able to withstand these challenges
and continues to deliver income to the
councils
the fact it's been able to do this is a
testament to the
investment approach and strong
management of the cifco portfolio
since its inception and which has seen
red rent collection rates
uh above the industry normal
the business plan identifies that the
challenges of the pandemic
are not behind us and continues to take
a prudent
approach to cifco's financial management
over the next few years
ensuring that cifco portfolio continues
to provide
income to the councils to support the
delivery of services
and projects locally as well as creating
a long-term legacy for the districts to
benefit from
in the future emily attack chris harth
and neville pritchard uh have a short
presentation chair
to deliver and then we'll be happy to
take questions
along with other members of the panel uh
we may all know uh all of us may know
all of the members of the panel but i
will just briefly with your leave
ask them to introduce themselves and
then move
to the presentation thank you chair
thank you before we do that does
counselor buzz we have anything he would
like to add
no thank you thank you
over to you emily
thank you so um i'm emily atack i'm the
assistant director for assets and
investments
and also the managing director of sifco
if i pass
on to chris
yes i'm chris howarth i chair the cifco
board and have done so really since the
inception of the company
good morning i'm neville pritchard
director at jll
and we've been advising cifco during the
acquisition strategy
and i've been working in the investment
markets in property for the last 33
years
yeah good morning henry cook i'm one of
the non-execs
on the board of civco
hello mclaughlin associate partner at
nsource chartered accountants and we've
been involved with cifco from
inception
thank you very much your presentation
thank you so if we could put the
presentation on the screen that would be
really helpful
um so today we've got a short
presentation for you
and just to highlight some of the key
aspects of the business plan and
the company's performance over the last
12 months
um as uh previously mentioned by the
chair the focus
of um overview and scrutiny today and is
to
consider whether the business plan is
robust and appropriate for the next 12
months
whether there's sufficient confidence in
the management of cifco
to look at whether the current
performance of cifco
delivers good value to the councils and
whether the kpis are appropriate
measures of performance
um both over the last 12 months and
those proposed for the forthcoming 12
months
so i pass on to chris
thank you emily um yes it's um i mean
it's an important
time in the in the growth and life of
civco because really
to all intents and purposes we've come
to the end of the um
the acquisition process we now have a a
portfolio which i
will talk about in more detail shortly
um the final sums were drawn down in
march
um to enable the completion of two
further properties
and also importantly to provide funds
for future capital investment in the
assets
um as we'll see a bit later we're keen
to improve the
sustainability and it's also important
to maintain the value
and that is really is now having gone
through the acquisition process
the um the focus and purpose of cifco is
to
generate income for our shareholders and
add value where possible of course to
the assets
um and we have as you'll see surely
you'll see if you've read the draft
business plan um
we have changed the kpa kpis as a
consequence to reflect that full
investment status
and the emphasis on sustainability
what we have created is a
diverse portfolio of assets and tenants
and the important thing about that it
mitigates exposure to
individual tenants to individual sectors
individual areas
and i think really the performance of
the portfolio
um particularly over the last year as it
has been said
you really couldn't have found a much
stronger challenge
um of a portfolio than what we've been
through over the last year 18 months
and that has really um proved i think
the
you know the uh the strength of that
portfolio
as part of the process obviously what
we've done the process of investment
it's been very important that we are
fleet of foot look to see
look at changing our investment strategy
if that is
justified by the market so for instance
since 2018
um the portfolio has been diversified
away from retail assets to
greater emphasis on industrial assets
which has been the much stronger sector
and i think the total net income
received by the councils today to just
under five and a half million
um since the uh the inception of the
portfolio
and i think as i referred to earlier i
mean despite the challenges of
covert the quality of the portfolio has
um
led to most vacant properties being
re-let and voids are low at
three percent we have had voids um
we have had tenants go into
administration but
um the quality of the underlying asset
that's been the important thing that's
what i've been looking at
is the quality of that um underlying
asset
next slide please um so the
the purpose of the business plan really
as far as the board is concerned
is to monitor the performance of cifco
over the previous financial year which i
think it does
it provides a framework and guidance for
investment
and management going forward it's
obviously a very important part of the
company's governance and it keeps us as
directors accountable against delivery
of the the business plan
on that i will now hand over to neville
who will talk us through the
uh the market
hello like
other parts of the economy then the
property investment market has
been affected by the pandemic and it
slowed significantly in 2020
and in fact over the course of that year
there were 42.7 billion of transactions
which
which was 18 down on 2019.
um having said that as things eased in
q4 there was a significant
uptick in activity and we've seen a
similar sort of thing
actually occur this year which is that
the start of the year was a little bit
quiet but there's been a significant
increase in transactions there's been a
lot more investor
activity and interest in properties uh
going forward and
here we are at uh close to the end of q2
and we've got about 22 billion of
transactions occurred so far but we're
actually busier than we've ever been
so the likelihood is that we think we're
going to end up at a year which is
probably
all things remaining as they currently
are
a much greater turnover of properties
going forwards to about 50 billion by
the end of the year
the the key sector which is performing
incredibly well
is the industrial and the warehouse
sector at the moment and
we've seen alternatives as well um
in particular some of the health sector
type properties
performing very well and strong investor
interest in those
the first half of this year has seen
a 291 increase in turnover in warehouse
and industrial properties
which gives some idea of the strength of
demand for those assets at the moment
and that's pushing values up very
strongly at the moment
it's 83 up on the first half of 2019
which we
can term as another normal year
so the returns that one's getting at the
moment on
prime industrial properties are very
short you're down to
something in the threes in the london
area and in regional centers about a
four percent return which in contrast to
the returns from the cifco portfolio and
um so the assets we've acquired
just shows how values are moving very
strongly in that sector
the retail sector is obviously been hit
hardest and has been in
a difficult place with the increase
in online retailing and that has been
accelerated
because there's a is there a problem
with harry or no not at all i'm just
saying i'm terribly sorry but actually i
can't see
the summary at all so i'm assuming that
what you're saying is what's in front of
us it's
i mean i mean i can't really see what's
up there with rays
it's are you summarizing that i'm i'm
summarizing that's right
all right thank you absolutely okay
thank you
so on the retail markets we have seen
quite a strong return from
investor interest in the likes of food
retailers obviously supermarkets
uh discounters homeware diy they're all
starting to trade quite well
which is positive and so
as shops are opening we're seeing some
interest recovering there which is good
on the alternatives as we would term
those properties which are not retail
office industrial
car showrooms student accommodation
still recovering slowly from
covet issues and hotels health sector
obviously very strong at the moment
in the offices sector then there's been
a lot of discussion as to
any changes to working and how the whole
demand for office space is likely to
look going forwards
the good news is that we're seeing
average vacancy across the uk at 5.1
percent which is
actually a lower vacancy than on than
the five year or
indeed the 10-year average so that's a
positive
and i think we're all finding that the
shortcomings of zoom mean that
it's good to be back with colleagues and
in an environment where you have a
social
and team ability and a way of training
your colleagues
the the fact is that investors are much
more interested now
in buying office
properties and they perceive it's a good
time to get in because
while sentiment is slightly against it
there is potentially attractive
pricing available and we've seen uh
6.6 billion of transactions in the first
half of this year so far in the office
sector
and a resurgence with some private
equity buyers
actively buying several hundreds of
millions of property
uh in the office sector to get an
exposure to that
before it becomes much more upbeat
and that's already starting its course
overseas investors have clearly been
absent but they've not been able to get
here but we've seen an awful lot of
private equity coming through
from the u.s in particular where people
like blackstone have put over a billion
pounds into uk property in the last six
months
and we've seen a lot of interest in the
middle east as well
there is still a very good demand and i
think the key message is to get that we
expect
the investment market to be rather
busier and more up to
upbeat this year than over the course of
the last year
i feel i should say next slide please
actually
just going through the occupational
market because the key thing to the
investment market is the occupational
market drives it it's not just the
weight of money trying to get into the
market it's the fundamentals of
occupiers because without occupiers and
customers and
people paying rent then the investment
is obviously
not an attractive option the
the fact about retail is is that even
the strongest have had a difficult time
we've read about john lewis with their
closures
and online is continuing to grow but we
are seeing independent shops starting to
be favored by shoppers out there and
in particular the diy sector as people
improve their homes has seen
considerable
amount of work and if anybody is trying
to get a builder recently
you'll know that that's a very difficult
thing to do the
the bank of england um
not not to take away from the fact that
coveted has been
very difficult for a lot of people who
have been adversely affected
but the bank of england has estimated
there's 180 billion in extra savings
amassed within the economy
and the consumer confidence is
increasing and so
one hopes that some of that will feed
through into
retail demand going forward i mentioned
earlier about the amount of people
starting to move into investing in the
office sector again is that starting to
recover
it's no surprise that last year there
was a much lower
take-up of office space than for a long
time but that was because nobody could
actually go into the office space
if they took a lease on it so that's no
surprise really
but just to reiterate that the current
vacancy rate
is lower than the five-year average or
indeed the 10-year average
retail growth in prime centres is still
showing
um some sorry rental growth is still
showing some
increase in strong centers with the
limited supply
and we anticipate prime rents will still
continue to increase
in the better centres depending upon the
local circumstances
again just to reiterate the industrial
warehouse market
is seeing unprecedented activity the
driver for that is partly coveted and
e-commerce and in fact over the course
of last year
uh 42 percent of the better quality
industrial warehouse space was taken
by what we term customer fulfillment
centers which is
you and i places which send out parcels
and that just shows that the depth of
that demand
set against that we've seen a continuing
lack of supplies as new developments
which is suitable comes forward
we've seen a substantial demand not only
from
the e-commerce side of things but
brexit has driven demand for storage of
components and stock
as people get worried about the supply
chain coming from overseas
we've seen a reduced supply from the
higher build costs
and we've seen the loss of secondary
product to residential
in particular with the residential
market being heavily
underpinned and promoted by the
government with the likes of stamp duty
cuts and first-time buyer incentives
so the fundamentals remain strong for
the industrial warehouse
sector and we anticipate ongoing
growth there and total returns in excess
of six percent for the next couple of
years
thank you
thank you very much neville um moving on
to the
side this is looking backwards really
looking at the key investment criteria
which we've used for our investment
over the last year firstly a target
portfolio yield of between five and
three quarters and six percent
um we've really focused on
strong asset fundamentals good locations
good quality assets
um and particularly you know on core
assets that provide security
of income it's been particularly
important and it's quite difficult time
in terms of lot size we brought that
down slightly uh
the upper limit from 15 million down to
12 million
um to just to give us the right sort of
number of assets across the the
portfolio to give that
um portfolio portfolio its strength
as far as regional buyers concern is
concerned they are certainly waiting
towards the eastern region
we've been keen to buy assets in the
eastern region we have certainly
never bought an asset in the eastern
region because it was in the eastern
region
but we have certainly looked at assets
very closely if they're in the in the
eastern region
obviously what is absolutely important
as far as the portfolio is concerned is
to make sure that we have the right
assets we give the strength
and the security of income and we do
have a a reasonable number of
assets in the eastern region um look
particularly the quality locations
where there's a limited supply good
occupier demand
it's very important to look at when
you're looking at the relatability
of a building and that's obviously been
particularly important
during the pandemic to make sure that
those buildings where
we have had problems with tenants where
we have lost tenants and we've been able
to
re-let them and again as part of that
obviously the modern fabric
with occupational flexibility is very
important
minimizing depreciation capital
expenditure sustainability
i mean sustainability always is a big
focus for us now
um to an extent what we can do is
limited by the fact that
the majority of our buildings are left
on full repairing and ensuring terms
so it's very often down to the tenant
the occupier
to drive forward that the sustainability
but obviously that is something which
we are keen to encourage tenants and
when we get buildings back then
obviously that's something that we
we're looking to really significantly to
improve the performance of the portfolio
um as i said so full repairing and
ensuring frni
lease structures um to quality tenants
occupiers who
suited to that location um that means
that the costs of maintaining the
building
is down to the occupier um and then we
looked at
strong rent reviews either based on rpi
or
upward only rent views
so we had a further 40 million to invest
and if we go on to the next slide
you'll see that um right page
uh that we acquired um seven assets
but to do that um we looked at um 111
assets
and it's important to bear in mind that
before we actually looked at those 111
then jones allowing to sell our
investment advisors they will of course
have looked at
several hundred assets before they
actually put them to us to to consider
when we looked at 111 we rejected
85 as unsuitable submitted office on 26
and out of those we acquired seven
so it's been it's been very much a very
careful look at a significant number of
assets to find
the ones which we felt were right for
the portfolio
of the seven assets acquired this year
um
five are industrial trade properties um
there's an office building left for the
nhs
and um a health center as well so
that uh total expenditure of about 35
million or 37 million with costs and
adding about 2 million to the
portfolio rental income
so just moving on then to look at the
summary you'll see here um
where the portfolio was uh being 2020
and where we are now in 2021
total asset value now um of just under
84 million with just over 5 million of
contracted rent
and an erv estimated rental value that
is of
um five and a half million so in other
words that's when all the
rent reviews and and inc rent increases
have gone through
um we now have a total of 21 assets with
90 tenants
and again that's good 21 assets 90
tenants that's a good spread
um we're not overly reliant on any one
asset or any one
tenant um the walt that's the weighted
average unexpired lease
term otherwise all about security of the
portfolio
has increased now to seven years to
break us in leases or to expiry eight
years and six months
and then you can look at the initial
yield figure
5.6 down a little bit i mean one of the
things about
yield and about the portfolio itself is
that
we when we originally started looking at
the portfolio we did look at getting a
small proportion of their portfolio
in slightly riskier assets which gives
more opportunity to increase value but
and and you would give a higher higher
yield
we found that over the last two or three
years we really couldn't find any assets
like that which
were at the right yield it was quite a
hot market particularly before the
pandemic
and therefore the yields of that of that
sector of the market were
compressed um so we didn't acquire
anything like that
so what we've ended up with is a
portfolio which is more secure
perhaps than we originally intended but
a very slightly lower yield which
explains
those figures there um
the the void rate um
it says here um 5.72 i think emily
that's now gone down to just about three
and a half percent
um and the um you can see the running
yield on the portfolio is about 5.2
percent
um now just looking at some of the
weightings within the
um the portfolio um
looking at the the sectors that really
reflect what i what i've just been
saying you can see that
high street retail um the
target weightings were 10 and retail
warehouse 10 percent
now we're down below that um but we've
ended up with the actual portfolio
the office sector is is exactly within
where we thought it would be
um but we have as we said earlier we
focused on the industrial and warehouse
sector which has been
a very strong sector looks like being a
very strong sector going forward as well
so we actually have 45 percent of the um
portfolio within that
um the alternative sector we're lowering
that we would have liked
more alternatives but it's again it's a
matter of finding the right asset at the
right value
um that we were happy with and that's
where where we've ended up
and then looking at the um
portfolio weighting and the the target
risk profile
this this slide reflects what i was
saying about
the um the security of the tenants the
security of the assets
you can see there and the target risk
profile of 2021 um
there's not five percent of value added
that's the little gray bit at the top
the
light gray bit at the top we really
ended up with nothing in that sector
so therefore we've ended up with a more
secure portfolio
with 69 of core
really strong assets 31 of assets where
there is some opportunity to
add value to manage the asset and
obviously that's important
um part of thing for the board i think
the board to do going forward
um so we've ended up with a as i say a
stronger
less risky portfolio than perhaps we had
originally intended
because of the uh the market conditions
and that i will hand over to emily
thanks chris um so this table looks at
um pacifico's key performance indicators
over recent times and shows the
performance against those targets so
this table is within the report that
you've all received
and but it shows that the target net
initial yield
was 5.75 and and we've actually seen
a an actual of 5.6
um as chris mentioned and this is a
reflection of um
probably the more secure portfolio that
we've um acquired
over the time um equivalent yield
target of six percent um an actual of
6.15
so within um just ahead of target
and the third kpi related to um full
investment
um which we um have got very close
to and in terms of uh actual investment
being 99.2 million
against the 100 million fund um
and then the final kpr relates to rent
areas
and we have a bit more information on
this um
further in the presentation but
ultimately
um our target is less than five percent
um this is um been a a figure that
obviously has fluctuated over the last
12 months
um and in the quarter four
when this report was produced we were at
close to five percent
last week uh just ahead of the um
june quarter day we had actually um
reduced
uh arrears to around three and a half
percent um with some
subsequent payments being made so and
that's obviously good news as well
so uh just moving on to um the proposed
uh kpis for next year and
the board has looked at kpis and
reviewed them in the context of where we
are
currently so we've obviously completed
the acquisition
phase of cifco and so
um we needed to review and
add in some new kpis so that they're
appropriate to sifko's
actual situation so the first kpi is
based on
um rental income effectively so it's
looking at
um increasing the contracted rent from
five million pounds per annum
by the first of april 2020 and to
cpi plus 1 so we're looking to see
rental growth in that area
we're looking at maintaining the
equivalent yield target of 6
and that's been a consistent throughout
a consistent kpi throughout
and the life of sifco and is still
relevant
chris mentioned earlier we're also
focusing further on sustainability
and so we have a new uh kpi
which rate relates to the sustainability
of the portfolio
so the current average um
epc score for the portfolio is a d
rating
and with a total of 6628
points and we're looking to reduce that
by 10 percent
um with a target that that would bring
us into a c
rating we acknowledge that um there is
still work to be done in this
sustainability space and we may not
have the right kpi um at this point in
time but as the market
progresses further and more indices
become available
then we'll obviously look at that but we
wanted to
have a kpi um that at least was a
starting point to show that we were
actively working towards improving our
sustainability
and then finally the um the last kpi has
stayed the same again it's a consistent
kpi
in terms of benchmarking zifco's
performance and relates to
um quarterly rentaries and we're looking
to
have that figure at below five percent
so um just moving on um
kovid 19 and has had a big big impact
on um cifco's operations as it has on um
the country as a whole so we have seen
five tenants
um who've gone into administration um
and one
uh company voluntary agreement has that
scented
uh been entered into and that has had
the consequence of
approximately three hundred thousand
pounds worth of bad debt being written
off
um in the last financial year we saw
voids reach as high as seven percent in
september
um and they're now back to around about
three and a half percent following some
of the re-lettings that we have
undertaken
um we've managed this situation um
by working with tenants and in some
cases
uh we have been um it's been necessary
to have payment plans with tenants
and that has included a range of options
um from payment
uh deferred rental or perhaps uh monthly
payments rather than quarterly payments
as is
contracted as you can imagine this has
had
some impact on civco cash flow
but as we mentioned earlier sifko's rent
collection actually has been
um above the sort of market benchmark
so i know this table is really small and
i apologize for that and i'm more than
happy to circulate it at a later date
or perhaps include it in the council
report
when it goes to council in july but this
basically shows that
um cifco's rent collection figures so
for example in june
2020 um at day 90 cifco's rank
collection was at 94.78
compared to 87.89
of our managing agent um workman's
client
um rent collection um and compared to
the
industry standard alt remit which was
only at 72.5 percent
so it's just to show um an indication of
um how we are or civco has been
outperforming its
the market in this space um kovid has
also provided
um some opportunity uh for sifko
as well so if i just move on to this
slide
and in some cases we have had some
premises back this is one of the
premises that came back to us
where there had been a tenant failure
and we've actually taken the opportunity
and to refurbish the building and that
has resulted in a much better tenant
being secured
and with a much stronger covenant
strength but also
increasing the the rent from fourteen
thousand pounds per annum to twenty
thousand pounds per
annum
and chris mentioned earlier on that we
are
keen to um invest in our portfolio and
ensure that
um the we maintain the value of the
assets
and so as part of our strategy to
mitigate voids particularly um
we have committed to undertake some
capital investment in the portfolio
and and this is a summary which again
this table is within
the reports that have all been submitted
and but shows
uh an expected um capital investment of
around
eight hundred thousand pounds in the
portfolio
and as i mentioned um we have
uh with with 24 kings wearing
in norwich we have taken that
opportunity to refurbish the unit and
increase the rent
and we have a similar situation with
some of our other units
we're currently undertaking um a
significant refurbishment for unit
at pasadena way which will really
enhance the unit
will help to improve its sustainability
as well as attracting better tenants and
higher rents
so in terms of the business plan again
um these points are all set out within
the report
but just in terms of highlighting the
main focus of the business plan for the
forthcoming year and we're looking to
retain all of the assets at the current
time
we're not anticipating any sales that's
not to say that we don't continually
review that position
but that's what we're anticipating for
this year
we're seeking to complete the purchase
for convenience store asset
later this year we're not anticipating
any further acquisitions thereafter
we're keen to maximize our revenue
and a lot of that is through proactive
engagements with tenants
and the lease events that are coming up
in the portfolio
clearly during um the tighter covered
restrictions
we our managing agents didn't have the
same
ability to inspect properties and i'm
working
obviously to reignite that um inspection
regime so that we can undertake all of
the
inspections that we ordinarily would do
and make sure that the tenants are
looking after the properties
and maintaining them appropriately
we've mentioned quite a few times the
importance to us of
the esg and sustainability credentials
of the portfolio
and that we're looking to bring forward
a measurable plan to demonstrate our
achievements in this space and we look
forward to reporting that
in 12 months time we will continue
obviously to keep tight budgetary and
credit credit control
of the business and we'll be managing
lease expiries
and we will be strategic in the
deployment of our
um capital expenditure um as is set out
uh previously
as always we will continue to monitor
the markets for opportunities
to enhance value and also income and we
will be
implementing individual asset
initiatives to create measurable added
value to the portfolio
um so again as part of um
our sort of prudent financial management
um of
uh pacifico over the next year um we are
looking at
um how we um manage some of our debt
repayments moving forward so over the
last year we have made 100
debt repayments to the councils and
however as you've seen we have seen some
impact
in our rent collection and and our
arrears and that has had an income on
an impact on cifco
with approximately 10 percent of our our
income
being impacted so typically the councils
receive over 80 percent of
cifco's gross income in terms of uh debt
repayments and recharges
so you can see that that would
potentially um create some cash flow
challenges
and particularly with pacifico running
costs that we have at around about
uh 17 so we're aware of these
uh potential uh short-term cash flow
implications
and are looking to be prudent in terms
of uh managing our debt repayment
so cifco is proposing that we defer
between six and thirteen percent of debt
repayments
uh for up to the next three years and
that
in effect an additional um late payment
penalty
interest will be payable by cifco of
around about 55
000 pounds if that full um facility is
taken
um advantage of and in effect the
deferred interest will all be repaid or
added to the total debt at the end of
the third year
cifco's intention however is that if
the business is able to make full
repayments it will do so
so for instance we are due to make a
next debt repayment in june and we are
anticipating that a full debt repayment
will be
made at that point and the provision
here is to be prudent
and ensure that we have appropriate
arrangements in place
should we not be able to make those full
repayments at any point
and just to to qualify that in the event
that um civco did make a um
a reduced or deferred payment
the council would still be able to make
its full
debt repayment commitments and would
also
still receive a surplus on top of those
debt
costs as well
um this table again is in the council
um reports and that have been submitted
and um it's probably familiar to you in
terms of
a format that we have been using for um
the last few years now so
in effect this table shows the
cumulative
income um received uh from the cap
from cifco to the councils and but
broken down
by council so you can see that
for instance baber has received
2.94 million of interest payments
after costs over the period of
pacifico's lifetime
and with an additional hundred thousand
pounds worth of
uh recharges so bringing that up to
three million
whereas uh mid suffolk has received
uh 2.344 million
um after interest costs again with a
further 100 000 pounds of recharges
bringing that up to
2.445 million
so the um the
councils this year have benefited from
approximately 2.29 million of net income
after costs and and that's equivalent to
about 13.6 of the council staff
costs um
the amount that baby received the 1.274
million
is equivalent to about 22 percent of
council tax income
and mid suffolk and receiving around
about a million pounds that was
equivalent to about 16.7 of council tax
income so just to give you some context
in terms of the net income that has been
received
um so moving on to cifco's accounts um
cifco's accounts have been
um circulated uh to the committee
and they were circulated last week and
they are still draft accounts and but
just in summary
they show a pre-tax book loss of uh
circa 4.58 million
um and that is made up of the
acquisition costs of the properties that
were required during this financial year
um a adjustment in value of the
portfolio of around 2.88
which is around about 2.4 million and
some bad debt write-off
and that i mentioned earlier of around
about three hundred thousand
and i have updated um this slide
um with the updated figures the report
was originally drafted before we have
the uh this version of draft account so
there are some variances between the
report
and the presentation but that's really
just
um because the report was submitted a
couple of weeks ago
and these are the most up-to-date
figures obviously the most up-to-date
figures will be included in the
council amounts so the report showed
4.4 million predicted loss as opposed to
the 4.58 million here
and so just um moving on in terms of
um cifco capital um and an income really
so um since 2017
and through to march 2021 civco has
accumulated
and some capital losses um and these are
around about
12 and a half million and are made up
are
primarily of the acquisition costs so
stamp duty fees etc when acquiring the
assets
as well as a reduction in value of
around about seven million
and on the um from an income perspective
if you look at it in
um in a cumulative way and that
we've seen rental income of nine million
pounds
uh we've repaid uh 7.3 million to the
council
and there's been net income to the
councils of five and a half million
and so whilst there has been um a
reduction in the value of
the portfolio and
this is um not unexpected property
values do fluctuate
over time and within our portfolio we
have seen
some individual properties increase in
value
and others decrease and particularly um
in the last 12 months the assets that
have been most affected by value
have been in the sort of retail or
leisure sectors as you would
um expect with the effect of the
pandemic
and i will just hand over to uh neville
who can perhaps just give some broader
context to the um the property market so
that we can
uh consider those figures uh in in the
round i suppose
thank you could i just just ask neville
the the presentation you gave before and
what you're about to give us
is that information all in one of the
appendices to the
commit to our committee report or is it
extra to that if i chair if you don't
mind if i answer that question
so the um the slides that uh
neville delivered originally all of that
information
um is within the business plan and
there's a section
about market and performance within the
business plan
however neville has updated um
that information so that the slide
information is perhaps
um more current because again that
information was provided previously in
order to submit the report
and these tables aren't within the
report um
currently and but we can consider adding
them to the council report
and if the committee of ov and scrutiny
find them useful we could certainly look
to add those
um in time for full council
thank you this is just taking a bit of a
long-term view on on the property
markets
and fundamentally cifco is a fund which
is put together
to provide an ongoing relatively stable
income stream
for the councils when one's looking at
property then
you're looking at total returns
but the total returns are made up of two
factors there's the income
which is the rent and the capital growth
which largely stems from the value
increasing over time and rental value is
increasing
the key thing about income is that it's
contractual it it's derived from leases
so the tenants are responsible to pay
that income and that should come forward
the rental levels over time obviously
increase along with that
when you have values then they will
inevitably fluctuate
up and down along with the economy and
there's a 40-year graph
on the sheet which shows obviously the
recessions in the 1990s
and the global financial crash 2008 are
the the low points
but across the last 40 years then we've
been generally in positive territory
and during that period not only
have the uh capital growth been positive
but what you'll see is the income return
obviously is positive all the way
through
so going forward um we are
you know as they say past performance is
not necessarily a guarantee of the
future
but certainly income streams
are relatively predictable they're
contractual and
as far as the last 40 years concerned
then they have remained relatively
stable
if we move on to the next slide then
that's
a fairly interesting graph as well
because
there we have the the all property
equivalent yield
which is the average income in effect
over the last 40 years
tracked against the 10-year government
bond yield
again you can see the capital values
have wavered up and down as
as time has gone through but the income
return has been comparatively steady
uh right about seven and a half percent
in the early 1980s
now about five and a half percent but
that's in line with lower returns
on all investment assets and in fact
in effect also shows an increase in
value because the lower the return
then the greater the value in general
so fundamentally just looking through
these graphs then
we've taken a 40-year view what we can
see out of that
is that as a long-term asset
property has performed well in terms of
producing income streams
thank you noah so really just a final
slide conclusions
this business plan provides a framework
to
manage the portfolio going forward as
you said earlier this is an
important time in the evolution of civco
we now have a
completed portfolio and to reflect that
uh the kpis have been and been amended
and provide a framework to
monitor uh the company's performance um
and that that change reflects the
completion of the acquisition
we've ended up with a a well-balanced
portfolio
um diversified risks across
sector location and tenant and that
could not have been
really more uh fundamentally tested and
it has been over the last year last 18
months
and i think i hope you've seen from the
summary we've given you that
the portfolio has held up remarkably
well we've maintained our debt
repayments it's
it's continued to provide very good
income
from the council the council our
shareholders
and that is going to be the focus of the
board over the next
year is looking at how we can
improve that income stream but also how
we can
start to work on on values improve the
values of some of the assets where they
have
lost loss values of its evaluation in
march
of this year was at a time when the
market was extremely hard hit
some units are vacant and
they have now been re-left and those
will be reflected in valuations next
year and i hope very much that we'll be
looking at an increased valuation at
that time
um but i would commend the the business
plan to the committee
he'll be able to approve it but
obviously we are here we have
the team here to answer any questions
that you may have
thank you very much um i'm going to read
out the
question from mr roger young i think i
confused members by saying that
councillor grandin's
a question related to this item it does
in fact related to
item nine so i won't be reading that out
obviously
but the the question from mr
roger young is why was it necessary for
cifco capital limited
to allocate 983 269 new shares on the
20th of january 2021
to each shareholder that's uh baby
district council holdings and mid-south
district council holdings when
uh and when and where were baba district
councillors
informed and subsequently agreed to such
action so is there somebody who could
answer that question please
thank you emily thank you chair
um so uh shares are allocated to the
shareholders on the acquisition of new
assets by
cifco and these shares represent the
equity element that is invested by
shareholders and was agreed as part of
the initial setting up of cifco
and so due to the process that's
involved in allocating
these shares they're often grouped
together where there are
a group of acquisitions happening all at
a similar time
and then issued in one one group or
normally across the period of a year we
may have
probably two or three share issues that
will be made
and so it's part of the process that has
been in place since cifco is set up
and is really there to ensure that the
equity is appropriately protected
um it the the shareholders equity is
appropriately protected and recorded
within
the company's administration
um have you answered the question when
were
councillors involved uh yes i have
so that was part of the process that was
agreed when cifco is set up right
when it was agreed that 10 of the
value of the assets would be invested
and by way of
equity and that equity would be recorded
in shares effectively because there are
two shareholders
and so it needed to be recorded formally
by way of issuing shares so there's a
process that has been in place since
2017 in order to record these uh
share issues and if you look back on
companies house you will see there have
been a number of these issues
and that have been followed in this this
same process
um thank you and the supplementary
question
why has a resolution dated 27th of
september 2019
giving authority to the cifco capital
limited directors to a lot
shares and signed on behalf of baby
district council suffolk holdings
limited
only just been registered some 20 months
late
or 20 months later i guess that should
be
thank you chair so um this was sent to
a company's house at the time of um the
agreement
unfortunately company's house failed to
register
um the notice sifco's lawyers actually
picked this up when undertaking some
uh company housekeeping and therefore
reissued the resolution to companies
house so that it could be formally
recorded
and so unfortunately it does appear that
it was a company's house um
error which we have rectified and
hence it being recorded at a later date
thank you very much
now members this is your opportunity to
ask questions do i have somebody uh
counselor dawson um yes if i could just
ask what the value of the allocated
shares
was then at the time
thank you following up from mr young's
question
the shares are um represent 10
of the value of the assets so
and the four assets that were acquired
at that time
and the share issue is
effectively each share is a pound and so
it's
10 of the um total acquisition costs
thank you
thank you very much mr chairman um in
regards to the lack of
opportunistic assets in the portfolio
are there any um restrictions that
we've got we're concentrating in the
east
and we've we've not got that much
in the northern cities we've got a
nottingham
um asset um
is there any way that we can um
is there any way that we can look
further afield
and um and get those opportunities
assets because um i think they're really
important for the um
that portfolio to balance that risk
um yes i mean as i said um we you know
we haven't bought any of those
opportunistic assets we do now have a
portfolio
we we can't really borrow further funds
because of the public works loan board
um regulations but obviously what we
will be doing
with the portfolio as we go forward is
looking at the value of assets
looking at where they are in their value
curve
and there may be opportunities going
forward for us to
sell an asset because we think we've
added as much value to it as we can
and therefore perhaps and there may be
other opportunities around
and what you're talking about there is
the opportunity it's opportunistic type
assets
there may be some of those in the future
that's certainly something we will be
looking at
but i think it's probably fair to say
that in the short term
we don't have an intention of selling
any assets but it is something that as a
board we will review all the time we'll
be reviewing it with
um jones lang our investment advisors as
well but
um so in in the future that certainly
may happen
thank you um part of the question was
have you looked at opportunities in the
north
um i think that there there is something
in the way that
sifko was set up that might preclude um
investing
in yorkshire lancashire or wherever am i
right
um so the investment guidelines will
probably focus more on the south east
rather than
um nationally across
the country and and so those guidelines
were just that
guidelines um uh rather than
um kind of firm fixed flaws and
but we have focused our investment in
the southeast probably for
uh one because that was what the
guidelines said but two originally it
was because that was where we felt there
was um
better opportunities and for us uh to
acquire
um and and that has certainly been the
case so far
whereas potentially some of the perhaps
northern locations we may have seen some
sort of higher
yielding but riskier assets and we
certainly were more focused around
and developing a secure lower risk
portfolio
thank you are you happy with that
counselor casting
and do i have any other questions
counselor scarf please
uh thank you chad um page 30
we talk about the debt repayments myself
go to the
two councils um and the additional late
payment interest
calculated is 54 000 as you mentioned
what level of interest is that
calculated out
and and is that set out in a
predetermined way
in terms of the governing rules of the
companies et cetera
give us some clarification on that thank
you
thank you so the loan agreement that we
have with our shareholders sets out the
interest rate
and it also sets out the sort of penalty
interest rate
should there be late payments um
so i might need to defer to my
colleagues
in the finance team but my recollection
is that it's two percent above
the um agreed interest rate for the
um the main loan and tuanta is
just confirming that so that's that's
the interest rate for those
deferred payments
uh councillor barrows
oh i guess it's coming um one of the
things that
uh obviously the the cifco fund
at sort of five percent 5.6
return seems reasonable but bear in mind
the whole of the purpose of this
operation is to generate income
for the revenue generation of the
councils
um are you happy that the net figure to
the councils is 3.67
because that seems very poor bearing in
mind the 50 million
equity that they've put in or liability
that they have uh to me that doesn't
sound like a particularly good deal
um bearing in mind that from a
cifco point of view i think performance
is quite good i think the
um bearing in mind the market but
overall the bottom line surely is it's
the income generation that is required
by the councils
to carry on funding the services that
are required for our residents
uh 50 million liability with a 3.76
for baber um seems pretty poor to me
i'm i'm going to defer that question
across to katherine steele
as the um assistant director for finance
for the council
because i think actually it relates more
to the council's
um financial position rather than
sifko's position
so if i hand over to catherine
thank you emily and the 3.67 is actually
slightly better than we anticipated when
we set up cifco
because we charge interest at five
percent
to sifco on the loans that we give to
the company
and at the time we set up cifco we
thought the borrowing cost might be
about two percent
so we were looking at sort of a net
three percent at that point in time
so the three point six seven percent
margin that we've got at the moment is
say slightly better than we anticipated
and obviously that has some impact on
the um you know the borrowing costs that
the council is uh incurring
thank you do you have a follow-up
question counselor barrett or other
questions
no clearly i mean if that's that's what
was uh in the original uh document but
it just seems a very low
figure to me when you consider
if this i know obviously with the
restrainments of the public works loan
board you're not allowed to borrow the
money to put into equities which
actually had you put into equities would
have been into 25
but not not able to do it
and actually of course i'm not able to
do it at all now with the public works
landlord of
cutting off a finance stream um
for this type of borrowing is that
correct
yes the pwlb changed during
2021 so we're no longer able to access
pwlb to do what they call debt for
yield type investments which is
obviously what cifco is
bearing in mind that that is the case
and there is obviously very limited
scope for
increasing the fund is it then the
point that cifco could be downgraded to
just be a holding company as opposed to
a managed
uh going forward an acquisition because
obviously you're you're not going to be
in a position to buy
more unless you sell and the current
market doesn't look as if
selling makes sense so would it be
prudent then to
reduce the management costs of cifco
to actually prepare to be a holding
as opposed to an acquisition type
company
and so the uh
the management costs for cifco relate um
largely to the external advisors that we
instruct and that is to ensure that we
get the best possible advice and protect
the council's investments
and so moving forward we aren't
anticipating um acquisitions uh
in in the in the sort of short term
other than to complete those that are
currently uh under offer and
the board of sifko has reviewed um how
the portfolio should be managed um and
are still of the view that it's
important to
protect the value of the council's
investment in cifco
by maintaining the the current approach
to a portfolio and property management
and that actually to maintain the
standard of
management of the portfolio and of the
properties
and to do it in an alternative way and
but to maintain that standard we don't
believe there would be any cost savings
and so we still believe that we get very
good value for money
and from our consultants like jones lang
lacelle
and actually during the pandemic that's
been even more important than
in in previous years when it's been so
important to have
um good relationships with our tenants
and to actively manage those
relationships rather than just
you know waiting to see if the rent
comes in or not
and so i think particularly during these
challenging times
you know the value added by our
consultants is really considerable
i don't know whether chris wants to add
anything further to that
yes i mean i agree absolutely entirely
with that and
i think it's a misconception to think
that when one owns a portfolio like this
it's
right this is just we've got it now we
can hold it um there are tremendous
opportunities for
um either increasing the value and but
also increasing the income as well
uh and and that's extremely important
particularly at times as we
you know we're certainly not out of the
pandemic we will
continue to see some effects from the
pandemics it's very very important but
obviously
as emi has said it how we how we manage
this moving it forward is something that
we
we review all the time it is very very
important that we
we manage the portfolio very carefully
have the relationship with the tenants
they're the people who pay the rent
which gives the the assets the value
very important how we manage that moving
forward we've reviewed it and we think
this is the best way
um certainly for the moment as to how we
move forward with the portfolio
thank you councillor mayberry
thank you thank you chairman and my
question is got three parts is that okay
thank you um
you mentioned uh re-lettings at one
point
um and i know sometimes when
a property has has been voided
there is quite often a period of perhaps
up to six months
that's given to a new tenant which is
free or much reduced rental
can you tell me if we have been doing
that please
yes certainly so we've negotiated
commercial deals with our
new tenants and in some circumstances
there have been
uh rent free periods that have been
agreed and they've been
um appropriate to the market for those
properties
and also any tenant fit out works that
the tenant may
need to undertake for those premises so
yes that's been a normal part of
um the re-letting of those units
thank you for that answer and would we
have
um a figure of how much that's cost
in lost rental please and no i'd need to
go away and have a look at that in terms
of the um
total figure um in relation to uh rent
free periods but i'm more than happy to
to take that one away and have a look at
it and come back to you
yes please i think that would be useful
with with the chairman's
um yes thank you very much thank you um
carry on thank you um you have
highlighted quite a few um
refurbishments that
vary in cost one was quite large
over four hundred thousand without going
through all the papers
could you tell um the committee
how long you think that that
reinvestment
in that would be returned by the rent
and i'm probably more interested in the
larger
refurbishment
so the larger refurbishment that you're
referring to
is um units two and three pasadena way
in harlow
and where we had a tenant go into
administration
um once we took the building back
we thought that there was an opportunity
actually to
replace the roof and it wasn't very um
energy efficient it wasn't um
in the best repair and we thought
actually it's much better to undertake a
substantial
change to the building like that when
the when the property is void
so the works are due to commence on site
and within the next couple of weeks
um and um will be completed i think
within a
three to four month period and we are
also considering
whether we can include um additional
solar panels
onto the roof as well as part of that
refurbishment work
and in terms of the the payback of that
um refurbishment that was something that
the board looked at quite closely at the
time
um to be able to demonstrate that it was
really an investment i.e
that you've got to return on on that
investment i'd need to check back at
figures
to clarify exactly what that return was
but ultimately the view of our advisors
was that
by undertaking this refurbishment we
would
um reduce the avoid period so
it would speed up the time that we find
a tenant for this
this this unit
and it would also improve the chances
of us identifying a better quality
tenant
because better quality tenants tend to
want to have buildings that are in
repair
and those and that we're likely to
increase the lease length of that um
tenant as well
and and that all of those factors would
have a positive
impact on the value of the asset at the
end
so we're anticipating increasing the
rent from
memory from around about seven pounds
per square foot up to about 10 pounds
per square foot
and that that would have a a similar
impact on
on value so does that help to give you
some
um some of the sort of justification
behind that investment
yes it it does thank you but i would be
interested in
in seeing the figures for that and it
it just brings to mind a little bit of a
query about why
there was the investment in that
particular building at the time
when it was recognized that the roof was
in in poor
repair um but i'll leave i'll leave that
with you too
to reply with with the figures and my
last point by may mr chairman thank you
is you you've talked about tenant
engagement and lease events
um are they a an extra cost
to sifco or are they not please
and so tenant engagement is really about
conversations with our tenants
and that forms part of the contracts
that we have in place with our managing
agents and
fund managers so there's no additional
cost
in relation to those conversations in
terms of lease events
those are things like rent reviews and
lease renewals
and there will be additional costs in
relation to those
to reflect the transactions that are
being undertaken
so normally a kind of percentage or a
fixed rate
um fee and we have included an allowance
within our
budgets moving forward for those
additional professional costs
thank you very much thank you uh anyone
else with any questions
uh right i'm sorry
i'll need a wing mirror i think i'll
take i'll take councillor mclaren
and then at councillor ekping young
and then councillor gould and then
councillor scarf so councillor
mclaren please i think it was a lot
easier chairman when we had a yellow
hand to push
um can i just make at the outset i have
quite a few questions
but at the outset can i just say that we
had a very comprehensive
presentation but i for one really
couldn't
see some of that and it would have been
helpful
and i'm probably speaking for quite a
few members of the committee
it would have been very helpful if we'd
have had
some pressy of that presentation in our
hands so that we could have perhaps
asked questions intelligently around
that presentation
but i felt a lot of it was lost by that
very fact we couldn't see it but that's
just an observation
thank you chairman um can i refer to the
papers
uh and i want to refer to page
33 in the in the document that
the committee had i'll have
sorry and perhaps i could have an
explanation i'm not
sure who's going to answer this 17.3
could you just explain to me the about
the phrase
repairing their own demises
certainly so just in regard to the
presentation
and obviously we weren't we prepared the
presentation
probably on the assumption that it was
going to be a virtual um
presentation which would have meant you
would have all had the presentation on
your screens in front of you so
apologies if it was difficult to read in
this environment
and i'm more than happy to circulate the
presentation afterwards
if that would be of assistance in
reality most of the presentation is
actually within the documents
and that we provided there is very
little new information
really the purpose of the presentation
was just to try to highlight some of the
key aspects
and so it wasn't really to provide
additional information but i'm more than
happy to do that
thank you and in relation to your
question um regarding 17.3
um so this really relates to um what we
call sort of full repairing and ensuring
terms
so the majority of our tenants have
leases which require them to maintain
their properties
so it's entirely at their cost and
expense to maintain their properties
and so that's what we're referring to
when we're talking about in 17.3 we're
talking about
um our approach towards sustainability
and how much influence we can have on
the sustainability of our portfolio
because if um 97 of the portfolio is let
on um fully repairing and ensuring
leases
then actually that sustainability point
sits largely with the tenants
rather than as the landlord but what
we're identifying as cifco
is that there are lease events that
occur we do get properties back to us
and in those situations we want to try
to do what we can to improve
the sustainability of those individual
units
and we're also keen to talk to our
tenants so
they will come forward to us and say
actually we're planning to do x y and
zed are you happy to approve that
and we'd like to be in a position where
we can have conversations with them and
say
yes have you thought about also adding
these other components in
which will help with the sustainability
of the building so
that's where it's important that we have
those relationships with tenants because
actually
in the majority of cases it's the
tenant's responsibility to repair the
buildings
that's part of the contractual
arrangements we have in place
but doesn't mean that there couldn't be
conversations perhaps trying to
influence them
to take more sustainable um steps
uh where where possible and we're also
looking at other things in terms of
moving forward so how we can add in
um kind of green lease clauses within
our standard leases where we have leader
rules as well
so it's a kind of bigger picture in
terms of how we can start to address
and improve the sustainability of our
portfolio
emily actually was about the word
demises i just
it was um is that is that a
professional word for property yes so
when within a lease you will have a
demise and your demise is the property
basically
okay and so that's what that was just uh
read difficult you know read slightly
um i did look it up in the dictionary
actually but i couldn't find
an answer to that i apologize property
jargon
thank you and i'd like to um ask a
question of the
of catherine the section 151 officer if
that's all right
catherine um the kpis
are obviously very important
that the cifco meet those
um in your professional opinion
as the other side of the business of
cifco
do you think these measures
these kpi measures are appropriate or
would you ever
consider asking for a change in those
i'm afraid my professional opinion
doesn't extend to property hence hence
we've got all the
the professionals sitting down the end
there but from a
sort of financial perspective for the
two councils that i'm comfortable with
what is being proposed at the moment so
in terms of
you know the loans that we're lending to
cifco and the income that we are
receiving
back from from cifco into the council's
finances
so i'm comfortable from that perspective
yes and
another question to another question to
you um
is the business plan do you think the
business plan is appropriate for the
next
12 months again from the financial
perspective yes i believe it is
yeah thank you very much i've just one
final question
chair um in
last week we understood that the
council was now the council was now
legally allowed to chase bad debt
at what time or what period will
sifko be allowed to chase bad debts
and so uh the government
monitoring on um chasing debt was
extended
um until next june and so the normal
practices that
landlords would use um in order to
encourage uh payment have been suspended
so we're unable to um
enter into a sort of legal process to
recover debts
and and that's the position until um
this time
next year and what the government has
said is that
uh tenants where they can pay the rent
should pay the rent
um and they have um added a sort of
arbitration element
into um progressing those discussions
and so that should we need to go to
arbitration we we can do
and but we're unlikely to return
to uh sort of normal practices for
probably another 12 months or so
and and that has been the case
throughout the pandemic
and and i think it's worth reflecting on
the fact that actually we haven't had
the normal measures
um in place to pursue our debts
and the fact that actually we have um
mitigated what our arrears have been and
that's been largely through a kind of
negotiated
approach with tenants and having those
conversations
and so we'd look to continue to to do
that
and um you know we'll use the
uh other options available to us as we
need to
but always start with a conversation
first
thank you emily thank you chair thank
you councillor egg pinyon
please thank you mr chairman
um we can see on page 19 of the report
that the
weighted average unexpired lease term is
approximately eight and a half years
and we then see on page 22 that
one of the strategic objectives for the
next year is
the monitoring of markets for
opportunities to enhance value
and income maintain asset liquidity and
i'm just wondering how
these two things actually sit together
and
our weighted average unexpired least
term how that
compares with the industry average
and would we want to be having a longer
weighted average unexpired easter more
a shorter one from our liquidity point
of view
so i think probably it's a question for
three of us
to um uh uh add our
add our thoughts on and so the um the
world the weighted
unexpired least um unexpired lease term
um it reflects the um the tenant
commitments
so it's the least lengths across our
portfolio
um liquidity and from my perspective is
is your ability to trade those assets
and so in many respects the longer the
lease
term probably at in the current time the
um the more attractive the assets are
within the marketplace and therefore the
more liquid they are
and so i think um you know that that's
um the sort of dynamic or relationship
between walt and
liquidity and there are opportunities
um with shorter lease terms as well in
that
we can renegotiate terms
certainly on some of our estates where
we've got shorter leases we have seen
those
um leases renegotiated and we've seen
some rental growth and subsequently
capital growth as well
so in terms of um what's an appropriate
walt
we're comfortable at the level that
we've got currently because we've got
some shorter term leases
and some longer term leases and it's
really about looking at the balance of
risks
um in that regard so i don't know
whether chris would like to add anything
yes just to say i mean emily's
absolutely right um
so there are some assets where the the
world is relatively short and for
instance if you've got a
an industrial estate with a number of
tenants where there is some rental
growth which can be
brought in by reviews or new leases and
actually
you want a reasonably short walk with
with some of them because it gives you
an opportunity it gives you the
flexibility to add value increase the
rental income so it is it's
it's getting the right balance in terms
of walter over the whole portfolio
we are happy with what we've got at the
moment
um there are certain assets where big
assets where
when leases start to come towards an end
then obviously we always that's exactly
when we'll be having
discussions with um occupiers to make
sure that we can extend the leases or
whatever is appropriate
uh neville will you have anything to add
to that
yes just to say that um i suppose
30 years ago the market was more used to
longer leases and it wouldn't be
uncommon for leases to sign up to
even 25-year term now that is not the
case
tenants tend to be much more fleet of
foot and
they expect to sign up for generally 10
years
in most properties occasionally with a
break perhaps
five years or something of that kind so
having a walt of eight years is actually
quite good in the context of leases
which is generally
in the order of ten years and as as
chris says there are certain
circumstances
such as an industrial estate where it's
actually quite good to have an expiry on
occasions because
if there's competition to let up that
unit you're setting a new rental tone
which can then be imposed on the other
tenants when their interviews come
around
and sometimes you need to have that
opportunity to go in there and prove
where the open market rents
are within that estate and
thereby demonstrate to the other tenants
that that's
the tone which they would be expected to
pay
councillor gould please
thank you chair i think in part you've
answered my question
as part of an answer to council
mclaren's question
it's around sustainability and it's
around the green initiatives
um and i picked up i think that you were
saying that
uh some of it is down to the the tenants
if they're doing repairs to
seatrip themselves almost and at the
moment it seems to me we've just got the
epc
as a target that we can watch are there
any other
rock-solid targets that we can
time scale that we can measure that we
can
use um for the the sustainability
bit really we had quite a lot of debate
around
a sustainability target both with the
board and with our consultants
and so the board were very keen to have
a target
and but there probably aren't any uh
sort of
industry recognized targets for property
portfolios currently
and so um epcs are
required for all properties so that data
was available
and other potential ways of measuring um
kind of carbon impact and we don't have
that information or data universally
available
and so the view of the board and our
advisors
that was that whilst we don't think the
epc approach is necessarily the best one
currently it probably is the only option
to us
and but we believe that there will be
more development in this area
and that's why we were really conscious
of saying this is what
this is what we're going to use as our
target this year it might not be the
right target next year because actually
the market may have moved on
the industry might have some more
standard targets that we can benchmark
against
and actually we'd like to keep that
under review so that we do have the
right
sustainability targets moving forward um
but we didn't want to not have a target
because there wasn't an industry
standard at this point in time so we've
created a target
which hopefully will will be able to
track our performance in that
in that space and we'll look to see
whether there are more
um applicable or better uh targets that
we can use in the future
i mean it is it's very much work in
progress at the moment um
i think it's really over the last five
years is
where we've seen the focus particularly
from occupiers and therefore from
investors onto the
the sustainability of the portfolio um
and so
it is you know it's an evolving business
and we we've looked at it
quite hard we're continuing to look at
it and as emily says i hope that
next year we may come back and say
actually we've got a much better way of
measuring this
and as as we've said before
a lot of the properties are out of our
control but then
there may be opportunities in the future
and that may be something which we come
to discuss with our shareholders as
whether we should be
perhaps investing alongside some of our
occupiers to
encourage them to be more sustainable
and perhaps some of the works which
they're required to do
that's probably not something which we
can do at this at this stage um
until we fully get through the effects
of the pandemic and everything else but
that may be something we can consider in
the future
okay can i just follow mr i'm presumably
sharing best practice with other
companies
with similar ways of working something
that you would do anyway
yes absolutely and that's part of the um
or one of the benefits of working with
um jones lang lacelle because obviously
they're market leaders
and they have a sustainability
department who we
um link into as well and get the
benefits of of their advice
and so we are at the kind of i suppose
the forefront of this sort of changing
and changing model and we
obviously take full advantage of the
consultant's advice that
we have available to us
thank you next i have councillor scarf
please
thank you um well interestingly enough
uh councilman mclaren and captain mcgill
raised
some of the points i was going to uh ask
about and in fact chris
actually in his final statement actually
answered one of them as well so i don't
have any further questions and such
thank you um councilman avery you've got
a further question i believe
yes thank you thank you chairman um
um i appreciate very much all the
directors being
here today and it's just for a matter of
clarification
um i know um mark sergeantson is not
here
i'm assuming he is still a director and
that nothing
has changed thank you yes
mark sergeantson is still a director
unfortunately he was on holiday today so
was unable to attend
and i'm sure he will attend full council
and we'll be very keen to but yes no
change there
thank you
do i have any further questions for
clarity please
i've just got a couple and um
one is about the management fee and
you've said a couple of times is it 17
or 17.5 percent
um but am i right have you said a
percentage
no so i i referred to 17 as
broadly the costs of running cifco so
that's not the management
no right v okay now that's fine um i'll
see i'll stick with the 17.5 percent
rather than talk about the management
fee um
is is that based on the current value is
it based on the original
um 100 million pounds
uh neither it's based on income right so
it's
it's roughly 17 of cifco's income
is used to cover the costs of running
fifco
yeah that's that's really helpful thank
you that was a totally different figure
isn't it
thank you um and um the shortfall in the
repayment
has that been discussed with the holding
companies are they aware
that this is on the horizon um and
when will it fully be repaid so the
holding companies have had a copy of the
business plan
and which includes this proposal within
the business plan so yes
and the holding companies are aware of
it and they have
excuse me have proved it as part of the
business plan process
and the repayment is proposed um at the
end of the three years
and either in full or by adding to the
capital
and that is outstanding
so we complete in three in three years
so
yes so repaid by the end of the three
years
or added to the debt effectively if
that isn't possible
thank you um are there no no other
questions in that case
we enter into debate who would like to
start the debate please
cancer casting
yeah just i'd like to thank everyone
here for a really
good detailed um uh
um piece of work and um it does show
that we've
we've we have had issues with um
kovid and everything it's actually in a
much better place than i thought it
would be
um after those so um yeah
i'd like to say yes this is a good piece
of work i feel like i've
had all the information in front of me
that i need and
thank you very much
anyone else if if there's no debate
we'll need to look for
we need to look for a recommendation of
proposal secondary and so on
um can i just make one comment it
doesn't need to be in a recommendation
or a
emotional proposal or anything um i'll
just make this point i'll come
straight to you and that is as
councillor mccarran said
it it was at times difficult to follow
the presentation
um and it would be useful if and it's
almost impossible from here unless i
turn around
and turn my back to you um so
it would be it would be useful to make
sure that everything that you are
going to refer to is is highlighted by
the speaker so if you are going to
talk to a particular table on a
particular page
it would be useful to know that um that
will make it easier for council
and if there are any um any slides that
you're going to show which
need to be updated that we have a chance
to see those
as we arrive and the kovid the kobe side
was very very helpful
um but i couldn't see it so
we need to find a way to make sure that
everybody can see
the same stuff and and can refer to the
same stuff so if we can
find a way of doing that that will be
really helpful thank you
um council barrett um
in the absence of any uh debate i
suggest we just put it through for
approval because i can't see much point
discussing i think the
question and answer session was quite
comprehensive and i think most things
were
probably covered by that um i can't see
the point of us debating stuff and we've
already got the answers for so uh
uh if i can get a second to let's move
on counseling
thank you mr chairman i i assume that
actually um
what we need to be considering are the
recommendations on page 17
aren't they so if that's what council of
barrett is proposing i'm happy to second
are you happy just to propose a second
of those as they stand
without without any sort of corollary or
any addition
if that's the case then
henriette i am very sorry but i'm going
to have to intervene here and say that
actually those recommendations in this
report are for council
so this committee will have to make
their own recommendation
we can make a very simple recommendation
saying that uh
the or you judge your unsecurity
committee enforcers or
sorry not enforcer endorses the
recommendation
that endorses the business plan to the
council
that that's absolutely right cancer
right young
so jane in light of that comment then i
i the recommendation
would be that we go forward with the
recommendations
instead of the council notes sifko
training activity and so on that this
committee
notes and then instead of the council
approves
do you want to recommend that the
council approves
so we'll just we'll just approve it
they'll approve it and then it all goes
whoopee
god dear
thank you actually on page 15 1.2
it does say that the joint overview and
scrutiny committee is asked to consider
the following and i think the four
points there
could be the basis of your
recommendations for approval
so would people like to with the
committee like to look at
look for that then page 15.
chairman i think we've seen those errors
that they've been discussed haven't they
all four points kpis have been discussed
we've said they're up to
standard the business plan
is robust i think we've agreed that
it's a sufficient conference the
management of cisco
are we in a position to really question
it i think they're probably quite good
managers
so on the basis of that let's move
forward shall we
yes but we do we do need a
um a proposal under an and under a
second
and we've got we can either go through
all of those four
or we can merely as i think you've
suggested
we take the the 1.2
our on block and that we have
uh investigated them and we are
satisfied that they've all been met
and that we can recommend those to full
council
so we've got a proposal in a second i
think we need to to
to write to write that out in some in
some way so that it is
a recommendation to council but we can
do that
we consider that the current performance
of cifco
delivers good value to the councils
we consider that the kpis are
appropriate
we consider that the business plan is
robust
and what did you want to do about
council barrett what did you want to do
about the
sufficient confidence i know i mean
clearly we have sufficient confidence in
this current management structure
well i'm putting words into my fellow
members mouths but i'm
i assume no one's dissenting from that
so
in reality what you're proposing council
about is that
um we we we recommend
or we can we consider we consider that
and recommend basically what we've done
that all those have been met and are
not requiring any further investigation
i mean basically we are happy with what
has been presented
can i just ask the um governance officer
if she's
has enough information in order to type
something out into the
no
[Applause]
yes chair i have that the um
that the joint overview and security
committee have considered the points
made
in bullet points 1.2
um and that the committee is satisfied
that the business plan is robust for 20
21 22.
um council barack house ecmo are you
content with what has just been read out
all right yes i am sure yeah thank you
so much
we are thank you very much so if we just
await the governance officer
putting that into the voting
um and then when it's there
we will have an opportunity to to vote
thank you
chair the voting actually just states
that the recommendation as read by the
committee clerk i'm happy to read the
recommendation again should the member
wish so
are you are you content that we've we've
had it ready enough times that we can
now
we're now in a position to vote yeah
okay
thank you so members the
vote is now in progress in your app
you might scroll down need to scroll
down to the blue line
counselor mabry may i take your vote
please
yes
councillor dawson uh is something my
system stuck here so i'm four
four that's fine thank you very much
council dawson
chair that is uh ten votes four and one
abstention
thank you very much
mr chairman could i just have um
um emily attacks a
confirmation that those questions that i
asked for
the figures would be forthcoming please
thank you
thank you mr chairman certainly
councillor maybe i'll send them to you
this afternoon if at all thank you
thank you so i believe we're now
at a point where it's all change and
we're going to adjourn the meeting
whilst um some some people who are
attending
can leave and others others not yet here
will
will arrive and if we can be back in
uh 10 minutes
12 or 12 for 14 minutes 12 30 and then
we'll
we'll discuss item nine thank you
account says can we can we please get
together and move
uh on to item nine
to start off with i'd like to invite
cassandra clements the assistant
director for environment and commercial
partnerships to introduce the report on
the
scrutiny of the review of the joint
parking strategy the process
and the timeline please
good afternoon councillors thank you
very much for having us here today and
for looking at this report for us so um
this report is for both councils it is
around the methodology and the process
for how we would like to
take on the project of creating a
parking strategy for both baba and
mid-suffolk councils
so just as a i know you've seen and had
debates about this
before but just as a slight um recap
the joint parking strategy is due to
look at what's going to happen within
our districts within the next five to 10
years
the growth in terms of residential in
terms of businesses
tourism and it's very much about what we
anticipate the needs of the districts
being
we would like it to cover both on street
and off street
so obviously we know that we don't have
direct responsibility around on street
that is the
highway authority within suffolk county
council however
you know your district's best we know
our district best and
i would like us to work in much closer
partnership with suffolk county council
in terms of what happens to on-street
parking particularly with new
developments growing
as fast as they are in both of the
districts so i would like our
strategies to be able to help them
inform what should be happening in the
districts
as well as assisting our planning
department when proposals come through
to them
there's just been one change chair if i
could say um
since the report has been published
so we've been talking to um external
consultants about who
deal with consultations for parking
surveys particularly
there's a number of consultants out
there and so when this
report was first drafted the timeline
was based on
officers doing that work which is why
you'll see it's quite lengthy
however it seems that there are very
competent consultants out there that
have done this
many for other councils um that are on
frameworks that we can use
so having some brief conversations with
those
it looks like we there's a number of
things that could happen in conjunction
uh because their teams are fairly
significant that they can take on
different parts at the same time
so the um timeline is improved
through to um it would conclude in a
probably summer
next year as opposed to december next
year
so it's around three or three months at
least off of that timeline
so today really was um for overviews
group need to talk to us about how they
feel this process
looks to you whether you feel it has the
right level of consultation
uh just to add the the consultation we
propose
is both face-to-face clearly covered
rules allowing and social distancing in
place
and virtual as well as online so there
will be different mediums for everybody
to be able to take part
the face-to-face could include a parish
and town council meetings it can include
um engaging with people using our car
parks that kind of thing
um stalls at whether there's um fates or
village
events that we can go to those kind of
things to try and engage with as wider
spread of people as possible thank you
chair
thank you could i ask if you're going to
trim say four or five months off the
of the timeline where you're going to
gain that because
as committee cabinet and council
processes at the start and the finish
that they can't be altered i guess so
you've got to
it's just a bit in the middle that's
going to be chopped short
is that feasible that's right so
essentially the the governance process
at the start and the end this is the
start of the beginning the the first
governance process so this will stay
exactly the same we're still due to go
to cabinet with this before we start
um and it is the desktop exercise
and the uh the data gathering and the
consultation by theme
bits that will all be done consecutively
now as opposed
as opposed to separately so you'll see
that they ran on after each other
the desktop exercise was august to
october
then day to gathering october to may
whereas actually
those two things can run simultaneously
and there'll be no hold up there'll be
no hold up in
employing a consultant to start quite
soon
no so we we did some uh soft testing
with some consultants they all know the
deadline to start the work is very
quickly and
um the ones that are on our framework
are all available to do that
so it looks as if they would be starting
in august
that's correct thank you
um members have you got any questions
for clarity counsel the mother first
and then council let pinyon and then
councillor mayberry
yes uh thank you very much cassandra one
of the points i actually wanted to raise
i do welcome this
so thank you for that is that i
understand the department of transport
to bring in legislation later this year
to
ban parking on pavements how can this be
brought into this study because i know
from speaking to residents this is a
major major issue
probably certainly some of my colleagues
in stone market and elsewhere as well
and i think it's really really important
that we perhaps consider this as well
thank you thank you
thank you mr chairman um
but i have two questions in fact
cassandra first of all
um as you well know we have serious
issues with on-street parking in stone
market
and uh you know we've had numerous
conversations
with you about that and have had some
temporary relief
my concern is that i don't i'm not clear
about how this
strategy exercise is going to address
that i have a concern about
how the highways authority are going to
respond because
um sadly my my experience is that
they're very poor
at uh dealing with issues to do with
on-street parking
and as you well know we have a an
increasing demand from residents
for a parking residential parking permit
system
and uh sadly this this particular point
um is one that keeps getting bounced
around with no one
really seeming to want to take ownership
of that
and drive it forward and i would hope
that as a consequence of this piece of
work that you're undertaking that that
would be a key
element that is taken forward um i
appreciate your comment about the work
that you can do to reduce the time scale
for this
but i am still entirely flabbergasted by
the fact that
you know the final drafting cabinet
discussion
that's all going to take an entire six
months i mean
when we're talking about a medium-term
strategy which is in the in the
five-year period we're
going to use up 20 of the time talking
about it
so um you know i'm more interesting
the actions that we're going to take to
to to ameliorate the situation
thank you um councillor mayberry please
thank you mr chairman you uh you've
caught me on the hot nelly there
because i am slightly pedantic i have
two
public document packs because my
computer will not let me into this
meeting whatsoever
um and in them i have three different
ways of putting this joint area
management parking plan
or a joint area management parking plan
so which one is it please
i have three different
ways of it being talked about and the
and the initials put down so what are we
talking about
so the joint area parking management
plan is something that was published
um in the at the end of 2019
so that's a document that we've referred
to that sets out basic principles for
both
of the districts around things that we
would expect to see
so that's what's referred to in as a
background document in the report
so this is specifically about the
uh generation of a parking a joint
parking strategy ideally but
it can be free we can do separate ones
as well so
this is specifically about a parking
strategy
so it's joint area parking management
plan
in 1.1 right okay fine um
the most interesting point
of all of this is my own ward in
lavenham
who have their own parking um facilities
they have their own
idea of what parking should be should be
like
and recently if you are if no one else
is aware of it there's been
absolute uproar within the village
because there was a suggestion
that parking should be altered in the
very centre
of lavanam the issues with this
is a county council
they are trying at the moment to have an
agreement with the county council that
the speed limit will be reduced to 20
miles per hour
the other part is that somewhere
baber holds a document and no neither
you nor kathy
orbeten have been able to find it for me
at the moment
there is a document that baba produced
which states
that within lavanam there are specific
areas of pavement with brick
sets in scwts
and there they can actually park on it
so does this mean that all of this will
completely make the local village
parking strategy null and void
please
yeah carry on thank you
apologies glasses and masks don't mix do
they um
so just to answer the the latter
question there councillor maybe so
the anything to do with the on-street
parking um
is not within the responsibility of the
district council it is with the suffolk
highways authority
so um if there are changes that they're
looking to make
then we can certainly give our opinion
on them
and and try and lobby them for what we
think needs to happen
but in terms of the the teeth i guess
for this document
this would be setting out our stall in
terms of what we would want
for lavenham and that's then for us to
use
you know have those conversations off
the back of that strategy with suffolk
county council
so i'm hoping it gives residents um more
of a voice that certainly through this
consultation that we will be able to
provide those that kind of data and
those kind of responses to suffolk on
particular
issues that are quite specific like that
again that are going on in
our villages at the moment
and i know this is just um this is just
an outline of how you propose to do this
but i can't actually see it seeing it
aligning with lavender
when they actually have the lease of the
car park the
this is off street car parking but some
of the on-street car parking as well
where it is designated so i'm going to
flag that up straight away
and i am going to support my ward
and in particular for this
of course and just to clarify chair for
me so the uh in terms of any
conversations with
town and parish councils about delete
devolution of assets so
in particular lavenham the car park you
you will know that they're interested in
taking that on
uh this strategy would not take any of
that off the table i think that's quite
an important thing that and both
cabinets have said that they're
interested in developing assets
uh so none of those discussions are off
the table through this strategy
and can i just ask a fairly general
question so this
this strategy that you're going to
develop is going to be
really detailed it's going to be almost
at street level it's not
it's not the sort of strategy that we we
discussed a couple of years ago it's a
completely different
a completely different beast so what i'd
like to do is have a nice clear
short concise strategy that talks about
what we want to
backed up by real data and then the data
be available for people
so i don't intend to have you know i can
imagine this being
um a number of appendices for instance
that that
happen that are quite detailed around
each place um
but in terms of the principles of the
strategy i'd like that to be
very user-friendly very reader friendly
that anybody could
download it click on the website read it
and understand what they should get from
our councils but with the data there in
a presentable format that we can use if
we need to
so we have got specifics around each
place
one of the things that i would really
like to see happen and actually it's
councillor penang's
point around the specifics of what's
going on in our towns
is that i think especially our larger
towns
stone market and hadley sudbury are well
overdue
a review by suffolk county council on
the the appropriateness of the traffic
regulation orders that are in place
i would very much like to see through
this work
not not after it's produced but during
it that we start pushing suffolk county
council to start doing those reviews
i think then there's a conversation
between the the highway authority and
the districts about
the cost of those and the implementation
i'm sure there's got some shared options
available
but that's what needs to happen those
things haven't happened for a long time
and both districts have seen significant
growth so i think we really do need to
take this opportunity to get down to
like you say street level to try and
make some differences
thank you very much um i'm now going to
read
two questions that have been uh asked by
catherine
councillor grandin who's not able to be
here she says
i did not see community groups
specifically mentioned in the paper
and i need to ensure that there is
specific provision made for such
groups when the new parking regime
enters into force
a lot of community groups in hadley use
the car parks to attend their community
meetings for example
groups associated with dementia and
their carers
some of these meetings last almost all
day and take place concurrently
sorry take place currently pre-covered
at the
hadley leisure center and ansel center
currently one of these groups already
has an arrangement with baber
that they can display special tickets in
their window
to extend free parking beyond three
hours without inc
carrying a fine and i've lodged a
request with another group to do the
same
such groups need to be specifically
catered for in the future
and there needs to be considered in the
paper so can you undertake to talk to
voluntary groups and her second question
is
it was agreed that charging would only
be introduced on the 1st of october at
the earliest
what are going to be the trigger points
for the start date
will there be economic and other tests
thank you chair so on the first point
about liaising with community groups
we're
very happy to do that and you're
absolutely right on the bullet point
list it's not specifically listed there
but that is not limited to those bullet
points so we'll absolutely work with
our communities officers and with
members to make sure that we have
all of the groups that we need to talk
to and and i totally agree
you know we are out there actively
supporting community groups to
to get started and and to work within
communities so we need to make sure
there's some infrastructure there that
helps them
so very much expect to have their say in
this
and i think the short-term parking
charges in baber are possibly slightly
off-piste but i'm very happy to answer
the question anyway
um so absolutely right councillor
brandon has said it was no
uh sooner than october and cabinet are
going to make a decision
around whether that's the date that we
still go for and we were very much
looking at
the government's roadmap as to how
things happened of course that's been
extended by another month now so i think
we need to see where we're at at the end
of that roadmap to see whether it's an
appropriate time to continue with that
piece of work
thank you very much any other member
nestled um yes i've got a couple of
questions
um this is the first i'd heard about it
being outsourced
um can you just clarify exactly what the
total cost is going to be this
consultation
and what the cost is predicted to now
outsource it if we don't
um presumably have the expertise
internally i mean what is the reason
first
you know for outsourcing is it i'm
slightly concerned that we might be
doing it because we want to avoid
any issues with officers such as what
happened with the licensing
of course so a couple of reasons really
for for outsourcing one was the timeline
i think we were always uncomfortable
with how long it was taken
as you know there were no parking staff
in favour of mid-southwark um
so west suffolk and ipswich do parking
enforcement on our behalf
and there's no other parking staff in
the team so amongst
the um admin support and the corporate
managers that i've got we would have had
to share that across them so
kind of taken them off of their normal
day jobs to be able to do this
hence why the timeline was so long so
that was one of the reasons in the
the amount of officer time it would take
away from what their
normal responsibilities are seemed
seemed too much to be fair and then once
we started talking
to our colleagues other colleagues have
used consultants for
consultations successfully
so we looked at that as a method started
talking to some consultants
and actually became very clear very
quickly that they could do
a much a better quality job because
they're experts and we're not
and actually the cost i think is going
to be in the region
of um collectively around
35 000 ish i would say uh so that's
then split 50 50 between the two
councils so once you've added up the
office of time that it would have taken
us to do this
that far outweighs what it would cost
each individual district to do that this
is
something that was sort of decided a
month ago or in the last week or so
no very very recently i went to our
senior leadership team recently on this
and there's a lot of work going on
around strategies at the moment and so
the senior leadership team have been
trying to align it properly
um so uh they may not appreciate my
honesty here
but uh the timetable for the strategies
so we could make sure we weren't
overwhelming people with consultations
and everything at the
at the same time we've tried to plot
them there was a nice
segue in for a piece of parking work and
so we've kind of taken the opportunity
to go
so everything's moving quite quickly
thank you
and the second question i had was going
back um i think you quite rightly
suggested
um that we could do this separately a
two-minute suffer and i think we should
do
because you know personally i'm quite
sure
mid suffolk from what i'm understanding
um from the council here
their issues and ours are really quite
different
and um i would feel quite uncomfortable
you know
sort of scrutinizing i don't know what
you know in hadley in sudbury we've got
very different um ideas the strategic
review how that should be
um what we would like to do in bay but i
think to mid suffolk so i would like to
recommend that this is done as separate
districts
yeah i'm going back to your um obviously
with the consultants coming in
um can we put a can we bring the
timeline so we
reduce it by six months and actually
have a definite date to june
2022 rather than december i think that's
uh what we need i think to have it uh
where we haven't got we've got
open-ended
um and we all know what happens with
open-ended things no one's got a target
no one goes to them so i think it'd be
quite good if we
actually recommend from this uh
committee that we have a
date of june end of june which gives you
a six month reduction
gives you 12 months to do it well 11
months
and i think that's perfectly an adequate
time period
to be able to do this i mean we're only
talking
well sudbury car parks
out of district lavenham we haven't got
many
and um i can't believe it's going to
take so long
to do this work um to get the data
and actually suffolk county council did
a lot of work
about 18 months two years ago they had
to
consult us up with all the cameras and
all the bits and pieces it might
actually be longer than that
she's probably about three years ago i
mean
that that's still available with all the
traffic movements i mean so half the
work's already done if you can
bear to go across the corridor to
someone in the highways
sorry up the up the corridors that
they're above
um and get that information it would
actually reduce a lot of the
work and i think we need as a committee
i think it's
perfectly acceptable to put a timeline
in
which is what we're actually one of the
things we are asked to do
so i think a 12-month consultation
period mr chairman would be something i
would like to put to the committee and
we can vote on that
as a recommendation for full council
please
yes thank you we can come to that in a
bit counselor maybe did you have another
question
yes um i did mr chairman and and thank
you and i've also
well they might be comments but we'll
put them as questions
um under 4.5 on page 40 you've got your
list of stakeholder
engagement but not limited to could i
ask that you actually add the ambulance
service on that
please within my ward we have
had several situations where ambulances
cannot negotiate
um to a patient um apart from the fact i
was
i think the phrase is nearly taken out
by an ambulance the other day on the
road but we'll
i didn't get the registration plate so
we'll pass over that one
um the other point that i'm
going to make is when you're talking
about that you don't
actually have the um
or the capacity within your department
now this is something that i remember
from 2016-17 and my colleague behind me
councillor barrett probably remembers it
too
which was when the ceo was going to
appoint
staff he was actually going to make sure
that
staff had the adequate um
the adequate capacities or they had the
knowledge for certain things
and i have spoken to him recently in the
last about four months over this too
so i'm really really surprised that we
keep having these come back
mr chairman all these types of things
that come back to overview scrutiny and
council
where it says we do not have the skills
within our offices
because this was actually put as a
marker
in 2016-17 i can't remember the exact
date
um and i think no
well it was it was far before that as
well
but i i do actually think that that is
something that perhaps this committee
should be looking at as well
if we are allowed to because obviously
it's staff and it comes under the head
of paid staff
um and the third item i would like to
draw everyone's attention to is 11.2
which is the last bullet point where
it's talking about electric
vehicle charging points well i could
write a book on this
because uh within my own ward we have
the situation
where we've been trying to put in extra
electric
vehicle charging points um uk power
networks come in and say
oh yes we can do it for this amount then
they come back and say
you haven't got the power supply so it's
going to be increased
i've had this also in my own village
where i live
we had an incident where they were
altering
they were trying to alter
a cable and they found out that it was
just a mishmash
and there was not enough power
in the village to actually supply what
is there
apart from these extra
electric vehicle charging points so
i think that that is the biggest
issue in what you're going to do because
how
do we get this power i think we've got
to
actually look at the households that
perhaps
need this type of supply
that they have to they have to have
their own
renewable energy supply to actually
make them work properly but i could
write a book on it
and if anyone is disputing that
council maybe is that a question please
will you include on the list of
consultees the energy supply companies
i think it is thank you please thank you
was that your only question uh yes i did
say questions and comments
thank you actually in addition to what
uh counselor maybe has just said about
ambulances
could i actually suggest fire appliances
as well
the reason i raise that particular
question if i if i may um share
i've been having a lot of email
conversations with um residents on a
particular area on cedars park in stone
market
in the last week about the bin lorries
not being able to get through
and i think this this relates to my
previous point
about the the parking on pavements and
this type of thing so i
have you done any work or looked at any
of the work the department of transport
have been doing to produce this
legislation which
as i understand it's coming out this
year that's what i renovate two months
ago on the internet
because i think this is really really
important
yeah thank you thank you did you want to
respond to that or should we just add
that to the list of consultees
i will i will briefly respond just to
say you're absolutely right there was a
consultation around
virgin pavement parking particularly i
really welcome that because i think
everybody in here will have heard
um things from their constituents about
the issues that it causes and i know
that i have lots of conversations
particularly about sudbury and stone
market about those
particular issues so i'm very much
hoping that that is going to bring about
some good legislation
and i too hope it comes this year
everything seems to be nudging forward
slightly so let's hope it does come
within this timeline and then we can
absolutely use it within
this uh consultation period
oh it keeps flashing on off yes it's a
big issue in the in
urban areas but it's just as big an
issue in in rural areas and much more
difficult to get
uh to get any enforcement i'm going to
take um
where was i cancer scarf and then
councillor carter
councilman mclaren thank you um yeah i
mean i'm
following on from what capstone will
have just said actually our refuge lodge
there are issues across certainly um
stone market where
it has become a problem but one of the
things that worries me about this
parking strategy is i think for it to do
its job it has got to look at the
residential parking permit
schemes within some of the urban areas
of uh certainly mid suffer it might not
be a problem um
in urban areas of the district of the
other district i'm sure it might be
but um the clamour for residential
parking permit scheme
is is immense it's not going to go away
and when you
when you launch out for this
consultation with all of these uh parish
town councils residents etc
you are going to get quite a bit of come
back on that
and the expectation as katsurek penang
has said we
we we've already got some amelioration
if you like by having
um the particular streets that are
really worse affected in stone market
having access to a lower
annual car park fee
but that's only for two years and this
strategy
won't be in for 12 months and what
worries me about the whole thing is how
we can influence as a scrutiny committee
the importance of the cabinet beginning
to look at
residential parking permit schemes
regardless
of who they think is actually
financially responsible because i think
at the end
of the day residents within stone market
would say well
mid-suffolk carry out through a contract
with
wesser and its which borough council the
on-street
car parking enforcement of waiting
restricted areas such as
double yellow lines such as limited hour
car parking bays
and therefore the logical conclusion
would be that they would also carry out
the same thing through an addition to
the contract
for residence parking permit schemes uh
and and i really want this committee to
actually
this is a good opportunity for this
committee to actually make a
recommendation
that the cabinet certainly of
mid-subject i can't speak for
faber members seriously looks at the
implications of a residential parking
permit scheme because otherwise
we're going to be 18 months down the
line we're going to be at the end of the
discounted scheme
and we're going to have the same problem
that you know has already presented
itself so
i couldn't more wholeheartedly reinforce
what council reckoning only said
we must we must look at these
residential parking permit schemes and
come to
a conclusion even if it means a
financial commitment from this
council because i think morally actually
we're morally
more obliged to run the scheme than the
county council
i mean we actually enforce it uh in its
other forms
so i can't see them can't say why we
wouldn't regardless of whether the
county council is
ultimately responsible or not thank you
very much
um yeah thank you um councillor carter
well to start with i'd like to um second
that recommendation
if we do put it in a suburb
recommendation for
my colleague here um it be over and out
it bemuses me when i
listen to other counselors speaking
about to be paying parking because
clearly
i've never had a problem with that you
know in a personal experience but
i have got the uh optional i have got
the fashion statement to go with it but
i digress um
when i'm looking at um in view
environmental implications so
section 11. i am pleased to see that
it does regards about the uh the air
quality and we need to drive this down
um i did wonder if we could actually
broaden
and extend the remit to just uh parking
if we could look at um if we've looked
at a recent um
recent thing done by the state market
eco futures group where they've been
trying to implement
no idling zones such as at
crossings and things so whether or not
we could as a
district put on for uh signs on each
traffic lights things like that it's
recommending for no
idling at these points um i did also
wonder
uh whilst we're looking at parking um
whether or not we could see about
driving down the
if the impact co2 impacts of the parking
bays themselves
if we're looking at we need to if they
need resurfacing
could we look at different um properties
of resurfacing i believe it was
was um enfield
are doing a trial of actually using
resurfacing of a recycled plastic on
their parking bays which drives down
not in the um it absorbs some of the
light and heat to make it less damaging
to the cars
but also has a less it gives off less
co2 when it's being put down
we could also look at whether or not the
parking bays
if we could be areas for possible tree
planting in between bays to
absorb some of the co2 and with the
issues we have regards putting on
electric points
whether or not we could look at solar
points charging
putting over a there was a trial being
done by
tescos i believe in i can't remember
where but they're putting
solar panels over there things were with
the ev points
um and also looking at if um
if there's currently uh solar panels on
to before the i forgot those arm things
that go up and down
for controlling everything those are
currently
used solar on i can't remember what
hospital but
they use them
and lastly i did wonder whilst we're
looking at parking as well
could we encourage our people to
encourage
businesses and the like who are put in
parking outside of the area
to look at surfacing that is
adequate for all and also looking at
before
any developed urban to go in there are
still quite a few parking bays going in
with shingle
and it is a nightmare trying anyone in a
scooter or a wheelchair
trying to actually get out the car and
to
access any property especially if it's
up the slope shingles near enough
impossible
does damage to the to the vehicles and
so if we could look at
encouraging putting in solid parking
air surfaces that would be also be a
benefit
so thank you thank you councillor carter
i think that i couldn't detect a
question there but i'm sure there was
one somewhere
can i go to councillor mclaren next and
then
we'll go we'll go into a debate because
i think we've already crossed the
threshold and we're into debate anyway
thank you chair uh cassandra i
i do want to add to your list um
we all came with lots of lists didn't we
i'm sorry about that
obviously park and rye
facilities should be in there but the
other car parks that have not been
considered
are hospital car parks
now the reason i say that is because as
a result of the panda
as a result of the pandemic
and in the light of say west suffolk
that is building a new hospital
long-term health care and i can't give
you any dates on that
is going to be more in the community
than ever before
hospitals are going to shrink in size
and therefore our catchment areas of
both westside hospital and
ipswich hospital affect both councils
and i think we need to bear in mind that
there may be
centres and if i talk about chocolate
peninsula
there's not many centres where
satellite care could say and i think
that would have a big impact
in our communities the other comment i
want to raise
is about your risks
your key risks and i'm sure
you perhaps can foresee what i'm going
to talk about but the
uh the risk about
motorist behavior
um you in your risk assessment
felt that the inability to influence
motorist behavior was highly in
unlikely i think that's what that means
doesn't it
i just feel quite strongly about that
and probably be
and councillor gould will probably
support me in that
that the shotley peninsula is a good
example
where you cannot influence motorist
behavior at all
and i just i can't speak for the rest of
the district
but from personal point of view i think
that
is very likely that you
there's going to be difficulty in
influencing motorist behavior
because as we've seen over the pandemic
in shortly cars just get abandoned even
if there are parking spaces
and it is not conducive to country lanes
or
small hamlets so um i
i just disagree with that assessment of
that risk
thank you chair thank you um
right we're probably into debate now um
councillor gould i think you were next
on my list
thank you thank you yes um you think
marks and glasses are bad you want to
have hearing aids as well
just to say this i don't know whether
it's the question that presumably we're
talking about car parking
but um is this car and cycle parking
good i couldn't actually see it anywhere
but um
i felt sure that that was the case i'm
not sure i completely agree with council
macleod i think we can influence
motorist behavior or motors behavior can
be influenced but
i don't know whether a parking strategy
is is the mechanism for it
personally i think public transport
improved public transport which isn't
asked a gift
it's not within our remit but if the
buses ran regularly
were cheap enough and they took people
where they wanted to go
people would be willing to lose their
cars but that's not asked a gift
come back to the risks um and
council mclarens picked up on one of
them but i'm interested in in risks
the third and fourth risks um so
the third risk talks about the inability
to understand and prepare for future
growth needs
for example houses business et cetera
and it says highly unlikely
impact disaster well i would suggest
that
uh without any castigation of spurs and
that we're already
at that point um because it seems to me
one of the
um influences on bad parking
um is the fact that actually we approved
planning
permissions or housing bills
where in fact it would seem to me and
many others that
they are located parking whether it's a
garage
or mostly garages actually are moving in
the opposite direction size wise to
the direction in which actual motor cars
are being produced
so actually people are not using their
garages to park their cars they're just
using it as extra storage
now you know i've lived in other
countries where
you know in such circumstances that just
wouldn't be permitted i mean you know
the garage is for parking cars
and and the the obviously the end result
of
not putting your car in the garages are
if you're lucky you put it on your drive
if you're unlucky
you talk is on on the play on the street
and
i think the issue is that today and
particularly in in our districts you
know where there's a
high dependency on cars for good or bad
i mean most cars have at least two cars
and some households will have three or
four cars
so you know our ability to in
you know affect the stakeholders risk
number four seems to me
highly likely rather than unlikely and
therefore
for me the impact will be further
disaster um
and i do you know i think that's
something that we need to consider as
part of
this um joint strategy work that's gonna
going to take place
um and i think other than that i think
everything else that's been said seems
to be particularly relevant
but i mean once again i would
make the point about the need to
seriously
put through an action that particularly
focuses on
parking permits thank you
do i have any other speakers please
can i can i just make one point that
occurs to me and that is
that i think that there are real
opportunities
for a parking strategy to influence
walking and cycling and the use of
public transport
because park and cycle park and walk
park and bus and park and ride as well
i i mean there's there's all sorts of
opportunities
even even in some of our tourist
villages i'm
looking not looking at margaret the
council of maybe just in case but
but there are there are a number of
there are a number of villages where
um there could be improvements like
the car parks could be um provided so
that people
are encouraged to walk um so i think
that there is
there is a real opportunity there
and and being able to park to get a bus
just as we park to get a train um
so i think there are opportunities there
um
councillor casting
just to add to what you're um saying
there
mr chairman um would carpooling also
fall into that those categories of where
a car park would be quite useful with
the a14 um
traveling going through our mid suffolk
and
you know other roads and baber um
carpooling number quite often a um a van
will pick up two or three people on its
way to a
further destination and it it does
cause problems in some of those villages
beside the a14 where cars park there
for you know for a working day but also
yeah i just wondered if you would you
were interested in adding carpool into
that
list of reasons
yeah did you want to add something yeah
it was just say i agree with both of the
points that you just raised really so
this parking strategy should complement
and assist
all of our other strategies so within
well-being within communities within
the the joint local plan within economy
you know councilman you spoke about the
sustainable travel plan
it should all complement each other so i
don't want this to be a really
restrictive strategy that just talks
about a physical car in a place
and doesn't take account of the rest of
the environment around it so
absolutely agree with things like
carpooling let's have a look at that
let's get that is that something we
support
so as i say i'd like this to be a
document that if a member of the public
read it they would know
our stance on what we think should be
happening in our district
and to do that it can't be restrictive
it can't be just closed off to a car
park for instance
thank you casa carter
thank you i did wonder as well could we
include it
look at a point as a accessibility
standpoint as well
as a um a parking standpoint if we look
at
putting cycle at bays worth of car parks
where you can actually access a bicycle
and also as it was brought up in a
recent workshop
um looking at uh motability
[Music]
shock mobility schemes where you can
actually pick up a
wheelchair spell or scooter
and possibly looking at drop-off points
where you can take it from one town
and leave it another one which actually
would not only increase the
ability for people to get accessibility
but also might
make them less likely to have to get a
vehicle their car to get from a to b if
they can drop it off somewhere else
yeah thank you we have got on our list
at 4.6 suffolk
disability forum so we could add at that
point we could add
um something along the lines of what
council okada has suggested
um i've made quite some quite long notes
here
things that people i feel would like to
see added
as part of the recommendation or um
and i just wonder if if i could read
what
and what i've got here if members would
consider where that might form
for them a recommendation to go
on to cabinet and one of them was that
we note that with the use of consultants
the timeline can be amended and
ons request that the final report to
cabinet
be presented in june 2022
which is what i think councillor barrett
was suggesting
um and then that there should be two
separate studies
one for each district and then
the the study to include everything in
4.6
plus the following parking on pavements
concerns about town centre on street
parking
implications of residential permit a
residential permit residential parking
permit schemes
voluntary groups emergency services
electricity supply companies the climate
impact of car park maintenance and
management
park and ride hospital car parks
opportunities for using the strategy to
encourage walking and
cycling use of public transport and
carpooling
council scar
with the sort of the general thrust of
that but i feel that
in particular with the residential
parking permit scheme particularly
that pertaining to mid-support that we
actually need to have a separate
recommendation for that because
um my understanding is that labour
members may not support that and i and
it's
one that i would appreciate going
directly to
mid-suffolk's cabinet in isolation if
baby members aren't
uh and i have got some wording for that
if if
that's the general feel of the meeting
yes if i may was the chairman i was
getting very excited there
um councillor scoff um we we do need
some
uh resident permit parking um
in sudbury definitely in lebanon and i'm
going to suggest some of the smaller
villages as well such as monksy lee
brentley
this is where they are heritage
buildings
never ever envisaged having a motorized
vehicle or somewhere having to put one
so yes we do need that as well thank you
because the scarf
my motion to include baby as well
so but i just feel it it its prominence
will be overlooked if it's part of a
generalized
uh comment type recommendation
as you've as you've written out we we
have looked at a lot of issues
this morning um and it's not to say that
residents parking permits are any more
uh significant than any of those other
issues but i feel that the prominence of
the residence parking permit
scheme resolution is one which we should
make as a separate recommendation
chair i might have to uh
is concert called leaving the meeting
in that case cancer gold in that case as
far as i can see
a baby over your scrutiny committee is
no longer court
three if if you
if you leave then the baby the baby
element of the
of your scrutiny committee is no longer
correct
well i think i think we are we're very
nearly there i have another appointment
very soon
right um so councillor pyong
councilman thank you chair uh very
quickly then uh assuming that we go
ahead with
countless casts motion i will be very
happy to second that
yes i too totally agree with the
accounts of scarce motion as well thank
you chef
so in summary then do we have we do we
we note the report and the shortened
time
time frame in the words i read out we
ask
that the that list of different
organizations and
considerations be added and we have a
and
and a separate part of the motion
is as councillor scarf has suggested
rather than
lose it in amongst the list that we
actually highlight that as as a separate
need to be considered
so that's the scarf
did this pedantic but um the wording of
my motion
would have said that this committee
recognises the urgent need for a
resolution to residence parking permit
scheme issues
within both districts and in doing so
recognises
that both districts will have to
consider potential financial commitments
to such a scheme
and that work on this subject must be
carried out within the jps
i think the the the the emphasis is that
the cabinet needs to start thinking
about the financial commitment that they
may well have to make
whether they're legally or like in my um
view morally responsible to to to do so
and i think
otherwise it will get it will get lost
yeah i fully support that and i think
counseling
were you seconding those sorts of words
um
do we i'm trying to hasten to a vote
to help councillor gould do we need to
read that all out or
um is there sufficient there that um
you can trust the chairs and and the
officers to
formalize that into a a lengthy
um recommendation to to cabinet so
are you are you content then that we we
actually vote on that
now and
are you happy that you've got enough yes
yeah i got most of your recommendation
and i will
pick up counselor scarf's and add that
to the vote afterwards
it will be now that we have the the vote
is for noting the report
as the first recommendation and that the
following recommendations as read by the
committee clerk
and in this instance i will take it as
read by the chair
so the vote is started on the agenda
you may have to scroll down a bit
cancer mayberry four thank you
so chair we have nine votes for that's
unanimous
yeah thank you very much so we've we've
still got
two um uh information bulletins too here
so do we if we are now inquiry do we
have to
conclude the meeting where do we go from
here
um excuse me mr chairman if i may
yes because there are two of us here um
the constitution part two
member six quarant two
so we could still be okay mary the two
m's may be holding support
maybe i hope you'll i hope you're right
but i thought it was three
yep it's printed off it says
do
you've obviously read it more recently
than i have
i've been at work what is the date on
that
councilman effective from the 7th
of the 5th 2019 unless it's been note
this is the same one
this same copy we've got here
got a bigger copy
if i can help the um relevant rules are
the babe and mid-south
joint overview and scrutiny committee
rules
which actually say that the quorum is
six and it must be
three from each council therefore the
joint committee cannot continue
right so this is just for bay but then
my apologies but i was trying to be
helpful
and and so um it suffered overview
scrutiny because it's called as a joint
meeting we can't continue either so
i have to therefore declare that that is
the end of the meeting
okay um
it's the best thing then to stop
recording and then
you can tell us where we go from here
so the meeting is terminated at 1 28.
you